Hey commentaries yeah we were talking
about the other show the talks about the
movies you love in this case Avengers
endgame yes we will actually be talking
about the film Avengers endgame first
time that's happened on the internet
long hairs Joestar Danner Alfred de Muro
people of people with endgame thoughts
oh boy it's growing up around hardcore
football fans you just start picking up
words and phrases and yeah there you go
me then yeah bull show last night they
really walked it in against yeah that's
90 crowd reference that I'm very I don't
know how much to say because I feel like
we really left it all in the field this
time there's a sports reference a
trailer everything I thought about the
movie anything else been game thoughts
nothing feel enjoyable after reviewing
it I only saw it one time in the theater
and after going back and re-watch it a
few times to break the ice trail
I don't know if this is gonna be one I
revisit all the time it's real it's a
it's a down well there is something yeah
the what can charitably described as an
action scene as Hawkeye's japan
adventure yeah is the first action
sequence and that's like an hour in the
movie yeah it's a lot of mopin yeah it's
mostly like there are moments I feel
like that people will revisit and
they've already been all gift so you
don't even have to advise watch the
movie all the good moments are gift but
yeah there are moments that are great
but yeah there surround but surrounded
by just so much yeah bummer summer and I
think kudos to them for having the the
gumption to do that to open the movie
that they know everyone is so excited to
see and can't wait they could have given
you the easy gratification like and even
you know the the payoff that they give
you with Thanos is like intentionally
unsatisfying
yeah I mean I think I get why you do
this with the series and I thought it
was very satisfying conclusion when I
saw it in the theater I understand now I
feel like if you were just gonna throw
on a Marvel movie I don't know
[Laughter]
either you have a low bar before you
watch Amadeus Dan what's that know
you'll instantly watch it some days if
someone mentions Mozart someone hums a
tune if you hear Motown yeah imma Deus
goes in yeah I was weary watching this
after we did the MCU honest trailer I
was instantly like dad rock out the gate
alright yeah yeah we yeah not shying
away from the yacht rock no although I
do get why they've they've given me a
Pavlov response to expect Guardians
yeah when there's dad yeah I was
expecting a ship you flying through
space what's their shape and it was his
yeah it was that yeah you're waiting to
see like all the you know yeah it's
weird it's weird for a song to play and
then cut to Tony and it's not ACDC
yeah he's ki kind of moved on from ac/dc
yeah you know he has grown yes as a man
as we see in the Avengers did we talk
about this in the in the commentary for
our MCU trailer where we realized that
in the Avengers he's playing ac/dc out
of his suit when he comes into
like standing up to bravely and there's
like opinion about weapons of mass
destruction but he still show me yeah do
you think he's locked in a rights battle
with Thor over thunderstruck yeah
anyways I should also talk about what
this show is if you're still watching
congratulations we have a lot of deleted
scenes that we'll get to at the end and
a chance to respond to some of your
questions and comments mm-hmm with that
said let's just watch shows just ready
for Avengers end game you stop and start
an old friend returns and this one oh
yeah after 21 MCU movies prepare for the
final conclusion of the Infinity Saga
and also part two of infinity war
penultimate film of Phase three entered
a phase four and backdoor pilot for
about three Disney quest shows who you
remember when movies just you know ended
and then your imagination had to take
over well sounds exhausting let's do
that yeah Thank You Gabe the most
successful crowd-pleasing global film
franchise is back but since life on
earth sucks now it's all about grief
boss kill it's supposed to be me
depression are you crying
and despair Dan'l should he kill all of
us because today's escapist fantasy is
in becoming a superhero it's going back
to fix your mistakes instead of scraping
by in the waking nightmare of your own
failure did I do it i mised on my life
it's a continuation of the character of
the epic voice guy yeah which is
different from John am I facing Lee
desperate yes but he is yeah he's a the
epic voice guy is in a awful marriage
looking for any excuse to to explore
himself yes and and he has a bad
relationship with his children he's
always telling him to go away he's busy
yeah no it's I just like how we continue
to lay depth onto the character of the
offense but Becht I guess the the
substance of it like do you think
there's anything to the fact that this
is like or the fact the what we're kind
of implying that this is a blockbuster
for our times that the reason this movie
is so resonant is because everyone was
depressed now and just moping around I
mean I do think yeah when there are
periods of you know sort of unrest or
uncertainty people do tend to like turn
to movies and then movie stores start to
reflect that like in the 70s you saw
that a lot there were a lot of movies
that were like sort of paranoia or
dissatisfaction with the state of things
sort of generally and I do think that
that's carried over into our films yeah
like to me I think the big fantasy of
the superhero genre in general is like
people could be all-powerful without
that corrupting them like that I'd be
powerful and good and when we live in a
place where like a very small handful
select group of people wield control
over so many things like it's our
fantasy that they'll be kind to us
it was literally Lex Luthor's point in
Batman V Superman Oh God yes line the
universes the power could be good yeah
well I'm not everyone's depressed just
everyone in Los Angeles there's the test
there's a lot of happy people offline
yeah exactly so there's an offline it's
sounds scary yeah no I well I think part
of it too is dramatically the Marvel
Universe is generally then one of great
levity and so if you're bringing things
wrapping things up I think you have to
inject a little yeah grab gravitas into
it because otherwise it's just another
you know lightweight adventure and you
have to have stakes you have to
establish things but yeah it's but you
got to start low to go get the low lows
in the high high yeah this is why I like
in some ways far from home felt like
such a like I such a change of direction
right after because it's basically like
a national lampoon's vacation movie it's
always it like just the pinging from
this to that was a real yeah yeah yeah
check the system so good for them for
having that flexibility only took them
29 2022 movies many to to like actually
have a moment of seriousness world is
quite dour this is not the first one to
be tired just like the most sustained
damage its earned our mmm-hmm
all right let's keep going five years
have passed since half the population
vanished or as introverts call it
winning the lottery now this is a big
head Olympic comments yeah baseball
remains unpopular the coach got frozen
in 2017 damn and an actor shortage has
forced directors to cast themselves my
crime pause just reported I mean I was
thinking maybe culture would I mean
culture would rebound actually five or
four years but yeah yeah I guess how
long would things take to like approach
normal to like get new trends like wait
five years
stop playing counter-strike like people
playing sadly fortnight and sure but I
mean I think I'm literally playing
through Chrono Trigger right now I did
just finish my replay of Final Fantasy
seven because it's on phones now oh gosh
yeah there's still three and a half
billion people on earth like it has a
population I said wiped out it's just
been half
yeah that's back to like the seventy
right so well you would not be like
these empty cities and there's no people
around to collect the trash anymore I
said I I assumed that that was that
there were districts in the city that
had been abandoned yeah this was
something that we could have or would
have gone into but I just assumed we've
talked about in other videos and other
people have done a better job of like
well well we'd really haven't yet I know
I wrote two actually one one was like
what would be the immediate aftermath of
the snap other than the people
disappearing so like this is how many
planes are in the air that might have
crashed all that kind of stuff in like
this is what would happen to America's
farming output or whatever and then I
wrote the other one about like would it
make people give up religion which the
answer was no no would not alright
anyway sir no the Avengers must band
together to do what every big franchise
does when they write themselves into a
corner
time travel weather weather Harry Potter
and the time-turner deserve to be in
there and I think the answer we came to
which isn't a very cinematic one was no
they hadn't written themselves into a
corner when they did it and was it
Azkaban yeah yeah but definitely by the
time Kirsten child came behind and there
can I went back to reverse old young
Harry's past when you when you write
nine episodes or something or or more
getting you want to change something you
gotta just come back travel back yeah
now what's gonna stop the Avengers from
doing this every time is it that they're
out of Pym particles is that gonna be
there expect him back then there's an
infinite sea he can just make more yep
Kenny well that is that was the problem
in endgame
is that hank pym got snapped so they
can't make anymore they've got the
supply he had good why they have to go
back in time to get more but presumably
if Hank Pym is back he could just keep
making them yeah Scott's been doing
random missions in the quantum realm
anyway yeah the whole cos Pym particles
is what allows you to shrink yes long as
ant-man is up and running in the wasp
then there are there are in play yeah
okay I thought that's what they needed
to go back though because because they
have to shrink and shrink down to size
lots of rub so you can't do that with
the ghosts um atonic around you know
they made 21 Michael Douglas interview
it's like a junket thing where he
realizes that you had to watch Civil War
to understand what's happening in
ant-man to does not have context on why
he's hiding from the government like he
had no idea one didn't even know why I
was in that yard to this movie what is
this we're at a funeral is it a wedding
heroes dissemble for now that's what I
call Marvel tour of your fandom with
several alternate camera angles on the
Avengers I'll have that drink now
a trip to the shield base where they
store all the movies closure thank you
the clips that demand you lose someone
you love or at least your work bestie we
we had a debate about this also hmm
I maintain that that I maintain that
that is a valid sacrifice because you
have you is it simply says that you must
lose what you love but we had to debate
about whether it should have to be like
a family member
well well no I don't think that was for
me so much the the issue it's like you
must lose that which you love kind of
implies you're active in in the decision
it's you you have to lose it like I lost
my watch whereas she is like bye
to kill herself and maybe she loves
herself which is great I hope we all
should yeah I think dance point is that
Clint still as a result of that loses
that which he loved still a second Clint
does technically drop her eye you see
that's why she now she lets I mean check
the tape but he's still they trick the
machine whatever whatever computer
simulation or whatever like security
camera is on the cliffs to make sure
that the proper things happen I wanted
to never replace Hugo Weaving I would
mark want he's is watching surveillance
from a distance is like I think he
dropped her yeah that tracks hit me he
looks like he's robbed but Natasha
decided to play a tree she was up to her
oh boy yeah I say it's fair game
I voted that it was fair clearly yeah
the the judge and jury of this whole
stuff I just wife is already dead cuz
that was like well she happy his wife
she's gone on he's already gonna get
losers matter of fact but she's already
gone and he's pretty simulate you're the
love you have automatically transfers to
the next most well-known person dead
guess I love Dan and Jonah
that's his wife and all of this gets
forgotten so that would be his the
person who loves awesome new sword with
the holes in it just throw his cool
haircut my whole personality around that
sword guys love this you aside he does
he should have died we don't mention
into the trailer but I don't judge
people by their worse mistakes
he's killed like hundreds of people now
cartels were all bad they all deserve to
be grisly torn apart so that so that war
machine a war vet who has seen horrible
horrible things could not even find the
words to describe the scenes of the
crimes to Black Widow and she's like I
don't judge people by their worse maybe
we should because I like because in by
Widow her solo movie she's going to be
tearing people this is connecting to her
battery which is she was a KGB agent who
was assassinating people and Clint was
supposed to take her out but he saved
her I know I break with the trailer on
Black Widow
in that I believe that her sacrificing
herself was the natural conclusion to
her arc in these movies because it has
always been about the fact that she did
horrible things in her past and she's a
character in need of redemption and this
was the ultimate redemptive act by
sacrificing herself so that her friends
could survive in the world could survive
Chuck I should know better where like
Black Widow was rescued essentially by
if the backstories to be believed by
Hawkeye from a life of a set of mindless
assassination of just going through the
the horrible the evil ballet she was
raised in is that yes
yes red sparrow sorry on a career path
you know you start out an evil ballet
before you know it you're you know
bleaching the Secretary of Defense's
coffee and how do i how do I get here
but Hawkeye has been an adventure like
he's been on the right side of the
morality his entire life and he's like
he loses his family tragic many very sad
in the snap and he goes butcher his
message to Scarlet Witch in and Ultron
is also like if you've done horrible
things just become an Avenger the slates
wiped clean sale of Avenger indulgence
is he an evangelical cards like deep in
there and we can keep talking about this
but we're nearing rage to justify the
existence of Thor the dark world in
applause that shot up rocket
wibbly-wobbly timey-wimey stuff they'll
try to explain 100 times either it's all
a joke or none of it is none of it's a
joke now explain yourself if you travel
to the past that past becomes your
future and your former presence becomes
the past which can't now be changed by
your new future
now explain it again with a visual aid
the Infinity stones no time remove one
of the stones another split yeah but
simpler they're not trying to stop
something that what you called magic I
call strength
even simpler changing the past onset
change the future
you know maybe time travels a paradox no
matter how it gets justified see
I think there's an explanation for that
I'm just saying would you like to share
I think if they explain through those
many first of all it's very obvious
we've got first started with the Russos
on the whole honest trailer efficacious
that Marcus and aphelion the Russos were
very concerned with people not
questioning the logic of their time
travel in this film or at least
explaining it to a point where it made
sense at least that when they were doing
but the cap thing and I said this in the
spoiler review so apologies if you
already seen this the cap thing I think
can be easily explained I don't think is
there like he went back and lived in the
past and ignored all these terrible
things that happened they they they talk
about in this in this movie the the
thing with the time stone that when you
make a change in a timeline it branches
that timeline to a divergent timeline I
maintain that Captain America lived with
Peggy Carter in a timeline he traveled
to a time I at that point it becomes a
divergent timeline and an alternate
timeline not the one that he visits at
the end but that he had a very happy
life and we don't know what he did he
could have been the most useful and
successful whatever for his entire life
and then came back to that timeline to
meet with Falcon and and Bucky at that
exact time because he knew when he had
to go back so like he so that he was not
living in the past of the time that the
whole movie the universe that we just
saw happened but that he basically had
Pym particles and could jump over and
say goodbye to us in other words it's a
timeline where Sharon Carter exists but
she doesn't know they ever made out so
it's not weird yes my
alternate-dimension itself makes out
with your aunt no your niece or
something yes fine by marriage and now
there
saying cuz I've read that I've read a
couple articles where they were like oh
well we think he might have been at
Peggy's funeral but just the old dude in
the back I don't know man
time travels weird yeah I'm just like if
it was a plausible explanation she dies
and which one does she die of old age in
I believe it's super warm yeah any of
this anymore it is he's got to take off
before they sign the sokovia accords to
go to her right yeah do they ever do
they ever say her husband's name or
anything like that no they could easily
just be that opens up the problem of
dead he would have any note it was just
Sharon Carter in his own timeline and
also that he would have at that point
allowed many many nine eleven and behind
her take over a field that's what people
just like a petrasis whole character arc
like for all we know he went to a
reality where he got there and he's
danced with Peggy Carter and then he
picked up the phone was like Howard man
listen there's some bad [ __ ] going we
need to meet up now don't tell these
people and we are gonna and and for all
we know he built a utopian future the
time and made and made the world better
in that timeline than any timeline I've
ever seen before
one question saying it's possible what
did he do with the Steve Rogers from
that timeline killed him would be buried
in the ice so there Peggy yes if he went
back to a post World War two time then
the Steve Rogers reddit timeline would
be buried nice and he's just modern
shield if they're like hey we should go
dig into the ice but no no
I'm sure it's destroyed I'm sure it's
this trip or he tells me where it is and
he's like if anything really bad happens
you got it he's like hey anyway Disney
Plus starting 2022 my explanation was I
just didn't care
emotionally it was a strong enough beat
for me that I was like I'm cool I agree
but so so many people do general I know
I know and I don't begrudge them like
I'm not shut up
but for me I was just like Dan Whaley
and that one you really drop the ball
all right Rose who aren't clogging up an
air filter somewhere like Ironman who's
really matured since Ironman one but a
steel the a-hole who'd rather die to let
someone else get the last word
I am inevitable Harry tell me mrs.
reshoot
I was just silent Captain America didn't
say I know you're spending a decade in
the present day has learned to curse a
[ __ ] he uses bad language this is the
one fan service the moment that they
didn't do in a movie chock full of them
he's a he curses in front of other
Avengers or in front of himself himself
shocked that that at least old avengers
cap didn't say language yeah yeah I
think that I wonder if they
intentionally did not throw because it's
like well that's the first thing that
popped into our heads let's see if we
can do something else but they did that
in so many other places okay we can only
do 429 yeah fair enough yeah thank you
God see guess baskin-robbins why
and look at guys butts that is America's
ass Thor whoo it's okay to make fat
jokes about because he's also suffering
from a very realistic post-traumatic
stress disorder what you think is cool
seen through my veins right now she's
with he's struggling on the runtime by
finishing his art before the movie
starts
I know it's crazy Hawkeye he deals with
the loss of his family by having a very
cyberpunk midlife crisis
we discussed several times whether
Hawkeye dresses up and the different
culture can you have like a big sombrero
like the bandoleros haha he's just
shadow running from his past
the tabletop reference I happen mm-hmm
thank gosh
cyberpunk midlifecrisis ant-man who
thinks of the Internet's brain poisoning
is a letdown every time he's not inside
Thanos his ass
that's a real chicken of the egg
situation was that something Renee talks
about that the internet just grabbed on
to and then it became a big deal or was
it something that was such a big deal
that the internet couldn't help but
notice it nothing there were Twitter
sees a feral hogs or the feral hog
there's no way to know I mean maybe you
could trace it back but I heard so much
discussion of good put fan of put
ant-man up fantasies but famous Venus
the pee-hole variant and that's how
they're gonna do it weight from obvious
joke to like before the movie open it
was almost morphing into a real fan
theory that is gonna happen which is
does I think it touches on the core of
something true which is that ant-man is
like subtly the most powerful Avenger or
one of them that like he could kill
anybody at any time but he's Paul Rudd
so do you but like at any at any moment
you know the people say oh we're the
Captain Marvel could just come down and
punch them now at any moment you get a
man your people just like he's he could
go microscopic and then you can't see
him moving around baby knows wouldn't be
aware of what and that's part of the
straddle so the amazing power of being
an adult man who can be totally filled
up on one taco which yeah
or maybe he shrinks himself with very
little it looked like a lettuce I know
what I liked about the taco is that is
something in the script that was
specifically written and blocked in the
script that they were like and then they
just nailed it just like they had a very
specific taco bit but they wanted it CG
tacos you'll see maybe ruin every movie
you see from now on is that people don't
usually eat the food that they're
holding or they never swallow yeah but
it's something I think like we're not
committed to taking a big bite of a
peanut butter so yeah yeah if you don't
swallow is a lot of congratulations Brad
Pitt in Ocean's eleven is my favorite
example of he eats he but he really eats
through the whole movie the only way I
get the characters just constantly
actually shot that one scene that didn't
Tokyo Drift social network where they're
counting down on that burger after a
really practice and like apparently he
had to eat because it's David Fincher
knees insane had to eat like 60 giant
fighting anyway Black Widow who finally
gets a primary storyline in one of these
movies killing herself to motivate the
boys worth at least you can tell the
passage of time by her hair that's
something rody but from the spring don't
travel back because iron 1/2 nebula who
ruins the Avengers plan so many times
the most helpful thing she does is kill
nebula
we're at the bar below who's so powerful
the movie desperately buys excuses to
leave her out the things that are
happening on earth are happening
everywhere so you might not see me for a
long time until he comes up with an
excuse to bring her in so Marvel can
finally have her lead the first
all-female Avengers team-up shot maybe
Marvel will let them team up together in
his sequel okay maybe they can all
posing in the background of the Loki
show however that that's one of those
moments where you like yeah until you
think about it yeah that shot was like
oh they're gonna all know they're not oh
it's done yeah I think I think the
reason that she leaves is like pretty
solid script wise yeah point is this is
happening everywhere else in fact it
seems like the Avengers are way too
concentrated on earth if this is well I
mean Jeremy Renner is murdering people
by the hundreds out looking for alien
planets or maybe like yeah you guys
don't need to come here your vengeful
sort of do can I speak to the manager
haircut
yeah yeah the didn't Beyonce say
something about like they need to put
all the lady Avengers together
no she had it would have happened by now
yeah yeah anyways cool moment but it is
a cool it's a cool shot I have to say
like a wave is a the same person that
planned that moment also staged Tony
Stark's funeral the most important in
the front yeah wanna come sit with us
they're nice people
he's Peters age it's true believe it
around know their own role they're all
like in a lie well you know the cameras
gotta they're all making sure that they
can get in there for the camera it's the
ladies get together for a big charge you
know he's not in that charge Maria Hill
hmm what's that what's that poor woman
got to do yeah yeah or Atlanta where I
believe there were no portal based
superheroes yeah
explosions baby driver Marie I'm gonna
do like coordinate like shoot a gun
that's the same thing black widows gonna
do tiny gun in heads is there somebody
knock them to sleep I'm wondering is
there a cutscene where Maria Hill is on
the computer and she's like guys saying
this is 20 feet from the college
someone's got to get to him like he's
directing traffic somewhere like he
always does yeah maybe from Atlanta all
right let's keep playing he did and
taking his place is old Thanos new old
Thanos younger old Thanos you know the
version who sits and lets everyone else
do all the work on the stone what will
you do wait whose life I'm a I like that
I like to do to bring back old Dano
Sunita literally makes the same mistakes
because he does not yet learned that
ends until first thing he does is find a
chair yes to do it just vanish from
infinity warriors and for Dennis from
pre Guardians looking for the host
Avengers pre guardians Thanos he's still
asking he's just been sitting on his
like big space chair didn't just bring
it with them don't you have it on there
big space shake chair yeah yeah yeah the
ship has like the stationery huge one
he's got a a second one that like floats
around all human
very lazy man yes I would always be in
that thing still he's on his like garden
planet just like hovering gathering also
they missed a really good opportunity
for a toy if like there had been a cool
reveal where they're charging at him and
he's charging at them in this hover
chair and it like turns into more Thanos
armor like that's a good toy it seems
like the shorthand for like retirement
or like you've done what you said just
go full agrarian or like like a house
immediately leaves aside I mean like
Kevin Feige has like a cabin in the
mountains these are like dreaming about
it one day they move the Avengers head
cause the Scarecrow with a baseball cap
except the thanks of a grateful world a
lot of farmers on the land Hawkeye has
in the beginning growing soybeans like a
family of three years yeah interesting I
wonder how long they have to drive for
they're disgusting they do that no way
for the elite street dogs you put mayo
on it and just mayo
after they were anyway have to keep sit
they were definitely gone sadly
definitely chat that was a brief dog
down in grief does someone else check
the tape for me I went back and I went
frame by frame and it's not many of as
it Linda Cardellini at Vienna at the
picnic table alright guys this is gonna
sound crazy
there's no hot dogs I'm into that there
are buns
there are condiments wait there's no
notice that there's no grill but I
assume maybe they cook them inside and
then just we're having a picnic I could
find no no dog no Wiener
on that table I think he shoots them
with a trick warming arrow you know what
they were probably gonna digitally
animate some hotdogs in then they just
ran out of time here's how it up for an
australian here's how it works
there's a girl by that target and what
hawkeye does is he has them whole he
puts on an arrow and he shoots the hot
dog into the my leg can we just buy a
grill like a normal
you mean with these arrow bucks yeah
he's got a special kind of arrow that's
just for filling everyone lines up and
he puts three on one arrow okay he
definitely was crying the first time
managed defense baseball's into I know
certainly since I've been facing sin GI
army the likes of which we have never
seen before since his last two faceless
CGI army now it was a lot of I'm gonna
say something sacrilegious and everyone
at this table yelled at me was I thought
the movie peaked after cap says Avengers
Assemble and then after that it's just
kind of the requisite gray blobs
crashing into each other that every
Marvel movie has in the third act it was
cool variations on the theme that we've
seen at the end of every Marvel movie
which is the giant massive armies
clashing it's like oh now the heroes
have their own giant CGI army great Tony
Stark hugged spider-man I don't call
that that I don't get a moment like that
in everything I get the I get what
you're saying and I kind of feel the
same way a lot of action movies
including this one I kind of feel like
it's a little bit too much of a good
thing you got a little bit less without
more impact having said that there are a
lot of moments that break up this final
battle there are great scene that is in
every Marvel movie I was kind of down on
some of the Captain Marvel stuff in this
movie you sort of tell that they did
this before they made her own movie and
had trouble finding Tara but the moment
where she meets and rescues Peter
money's delightful and like there's
enough stuff in there to keep this movie
black panther with the gauntlet yeah I
like running with
yeah I liked a lot of the moments of
that Plus that that just the two sides
coming together and you have every hero
to give the splash page yes page man
spider-man riding a Pegasus introducing
himself to everybody which is really
cute yeah I disagree there's that when
there's that many things happening my
eyes glaze over it's like every corner
of the frame has something fighting
something else is like I don't I don't
know well that's when you hit pause and
you're like there's enough little payoff
moments her saying cap and and so many
that I didn't even catch yes that's
going back over you're like oh you guys
have done the Internet's job for me of
yelling at me my feelings are keep going
a lot of people I didn't notice in the
comments we didn't talk about how goofy
and not you useful Thanos his sword
would be here
does anybody have thoughts about like
this huge double-sided broken shield
yeah it's pretty that's pretty easy
alright second internet we have three
swords good some people saying that they
didn't like like oh so Santos breaks
caps unbreakable shield with this sort
of like a sword that swords which came
from space it came from like a meteor
yes yes oh and a black panther prologue
teaches us has vibranium plus there you
go the villain of 22 movies like hit his
shield and cap was like haha unbreakable
shield the end of the day this was a
breakable in the 40 so nothing could
ruling so yeah sorry better movie
thank you good but whatever watching the
fight Thunder camp was the best moment
of my life
and I'm including the birth of my
children guys sorry kids you're just not
worthy of my time and attention so in a
world where everyone hates Game of
Thrones now everyone's worried about
Star Wars and JK Rowling won't stop
crapping on the floor for legacy here's
a minor miracle we got a satisfying
conclusion to a global nerd franchise
now just do it again forever or the
entire film industry will collapse no
sympathy from us Disney you did this to
yourself
[Music]
Spencer this is a catch from you yeah
and that clinched it clinched it yeah
man he does a lot of job acting pause
well perhaps we're gonna are you gonna
address what many people wanted in this
montage in our user comments like that
they wanted a shot of his but like he
says Haskell inches but no Captain
America clenches digitally clenched caps
you guys were being contacts the guy in
charge of putting the hot dogs on linen
carly's he could do it I bet he clinched
it if ant-man was trying to get up there
yeah I want to just take a moment to
give some love to the clenches timing
with the cymbals like like his clenched
was conducting a John Philip Sousa well
does heaven well done Kevin well done
all right let's keep clenching
and hardly wait five myths
Bojack Norseman Jeremy Renner's one big
one I love it go downstairs go help I
actually kind of like I'm like now the
contrary I'm speaking against our own
trailer I liked it they showed that
there were potentially others doing
their part in the fight well doing the
least possible she's protecting her
corner of the city
yeah it showed that it was a
wide-ranging fight I guess the issue
more for me was then they have a CGI
blob armies worth of sorcerers where
were they doing a good job
supreme yeah because she's not active at
all like they don't know who she is
until dr. strange takes over it's
basically like Earth doesn't even have a
sorceress oh no I feel like part of the
arc of the Doctor Strange movie is they
have a very narrow focal point of what
Wizards this the stupid they had a very
narrow focus Wizards were supposed to do
on earth which was protect time stone
protect these houses and that was kind
of it yeah and if you sort of move out
of that then you're you're over you're
abusing your power a little bit I think
they had a very narrow focus so she is
protecting house and protecting rock
area she's drawing power from the Dark
Dimension to protect one building in New
York
yeah but I'm snow well which is a which
is linked to many other buildings
collectively she's protecting all of
Gotham there are many symptoms she is
the protector of one but she's also the
ancient one so she also trains people
why didn't she turn back time well you
can have to ask that of everything I
mean that yeah she also knew that Doctor
Strange was coming like she knew there
was gonna be someone who was like more
badass than her so maybe she felt like
he got it mm-hmm
she also knew the Thanos is coming she's
kind like the watcher
interventionist yeah woman from Earth
not like some aliens like I won't miss
it first offense
it's also part of the central conflict
well it turns she would tell like what
turns his character against dr. strange
in the movie is that he did feel like
dr. strange was extending beyond what
they do
mm-hmm yeah yeah she might not have
known Thanos was like she's not a mitten
Rick if she doesn't know what Stephen
was gonna do with this dump
she dies like she only knows what
happens up to the moment of her death
she's apologized all Stephens it's only
if you're a wizard and you call yourself
Stephen instead of dr. strange you have
to go with dr. strange oh that sure she
doesn't she can't see past her she can't
see past her own death she says that
right before she dies even in the film
dr. strange so she doesn't have known
all that was going to happen a man with
a very strange mid-atlantic Gator he
won't speak properly but he'll be very
powerful this okay keep going
we need more Rousseau's give me more
Rousseau ex-girlfriend
Werther's original Avenger and Rat Man
and time babe coming soon to Disney plus
I love you 2.8 billion
nicely done day mm-hmm oh my god your
mobile plane is still active quit you
gotta turn off auto pay man
yeah that's dramatic license yesterday
well we were debating whether the stuff
in your pockets vanished with you and I
think yes it does yeah because
Soulja had his gun yeah otherwise at the
moment everybody here like far from home
we see people rear and their instruments
yeah and they have everything that
they're holding on where you're touching
yeah we've been talking enough let's do
it so much and a daring raid on a score
to steal the ether without any new
footage from Natalie Portman in applaud
held together by a whole bunch of
wibbly-wobbly timey-wimey stuff they'll
try to explain 100 times if you travel
to the past guess which way we're
leading yeah that was I think that was
the joke he wanted to make wasn't that
there was a lot of time travel
explanation which is really that joke
but more that they went to great lengths
to try to justifiably explain yeah you
know the other time-travel thing I just
I just want to put out there is that
it's not real yes that is important like
I think that's input whatever anyone's
like but wait a minute then this movie
got it right did they did they or is it
fake made-up thing no movie gets
time-travel right unless we can really
time travel after watch yeah it's not
like you can look at moving be like Oh
in this Louie pest or movie they got the
rabies vaccine wrong like that is a
thing you can do
no we know how to make that vaccine no
it would have been a same with this time
travel movie getting provable time
travel wrong but it's its fate well I
was about to say something but I think
it's this deleted scene so I'll let that
do the talking I've already done and
there either it's all a joke or none of
it is Tony Stark self time travel
between dinner in a small child falling
asleep we know it's a joke yeah boss
Tony cracks the cone in granted he's
like all right let's try one more thing
so presumably he tried some other I've
been doing it for a couple weeks cleared
of statements to his magic computer he's
just like invert that okay worked ok can
we talk about fruit pops pops pops yeah
that was not a term I had heard no and
we represent several various regions pop
cities not from the never Maps announced
I would always have called that a
popsicle spot I've said ice pop oh yeah
yeah yeah I just pop now I have a theory
is that never heard otter pop now otter
pop we have yeah that's a self but
that's like I'm right but you're from
Kentucky but we had in Arkansas yeah
yeah didn't know her we had all had
Pepper Potts in this film has become
with Paltrow I would not make she would
not buy popsicles squeezed this probably
was a Paltrow knows I feel like this was
a falter I know like Oh pepper would not
serve popsicle store-bought obstacles
these are made with moon crystals let's
make a very or he hides them in the
garage in Fanny stone Jade egg
I just have to look that one up all
right keep going
that also goes that they doses but look
at guys butts that is America's antics
so it's gonna be an even bigger
adjustment to go back to the 50s
dude seen Star Wars and hurt Marvin Gaye
he's gonna get bored a shuffle dancing
real fast
yep the husk I mean his boss is a black
guy best friend as a black guy yeah he
has he's adjusted to our modern mores
and ways and granted he was very a
progressive man of the 50s or the 40s
yeah but still that's gonna be tough to
go back pre Civil Rights Eric Steve
Rogers Oh Gary Internet the internet pre
everything free iphone it just is
another opportunity for him to shave
Time Machine and Google and with a lot
of knowledge that could better humanity
holy bitched up so that in the prime
timeline that that exists notebook that
gay man and like Star Wars yeah like
that he's gonna come back it's like
brother
captain's comes back is like black
people are cool now I'm Captain America
or like whatever and fixes it give me a
lot of that's exactly what the poster
says uncomfortable conversations on that
shield base straight comments to
Catholic hold on it sir that's not a
probe do you think he's dumb dumb
intention but he's like talking over
like civil rights leaders and stuff like
this guy has a dream I can't wait to
hear 50 Steve's call someone problematic
so you've decided to mansplain you
should reconsider
red skull you cancelled the hog who
resolved all of his character issues
off-screen hey that was easy
I'm so confused Brody audience standed
in now just do it again forever or the
entire film industry will collapse
no pressure Disney story last night our
DJ saved my life like that dr. Deon
Brinkley is finally done with all these
Marvel movies what's he gonna do about
like I can't wait to be done so he wants
to do two more like snowpiercer like
indie stuff no Robert died jr. has done
his passion project it's the untitled I
think dr. John Brinkley movie like who
cuz he he is a like a snake-oil doctor
who counted goat testicles as the cure
for everything yeah and it stars ruff
Tangier and Tom hunt Richard Linklater's
doing it's Richard Linklater written I
don't know if written but directed by
Richard yeah that is his follow-up
project is the goat balls
Capital make the goat balls move and
like MCU fans are gonna see it because
it's Robert Downey jr. and Tom hauling
together again and they're like mountain
goat okay keep going
Denver's ex machina stormtrooper
armie hammer you langover he's God's
Todd's pause I missed that all the
controversy where Scarlett Johansson
said she could play white black Asian a
tree yeah that actor should be able to
play any roles that they so desire and
included amongst those options a church
retreat yes she treat light creature a
tree white buckaroos some meta
commentary when her and Hawkeye were in
the streets of Asia and you should be
should have found somebody else to play
the scene is she just from like the
Brando School of Acting or she's like no
no a Kryptonian would look like movies a
tree well it's maybe he's a donut it's
for me it's the it's the Jurassic Park
like
we can but we never asked if we should
like there are black and female and well
not reactors but they're people who can
play those parts that aren't Scarlett
Johansson and that aren't getting work
and then aren't getting I don't know if
you edit The Groundlings lately but
there's a couple of Oaks
make you rethink that's a very leaf
estate I don't appreciate it just really
getting back to their roots maybe in
10,000 years when all the work has been
done when we're all beige yeah like yeah
we could but first we have to do the
work like yeah you can yeah and she
frequently does stopping her from
playing whatever role she blazes all
right anyways I needed that joke I
explained to me but yes deity I need to
go to office well it's okay
Thor tonight finally last week which is
a 16 yeah like some tweet of some
comedian was like every time it's me to
my girlfriend
every time chappy appears on screen
quote that's love it alright you'll see
that more anytime there's a robot
cyborgs and which mean the
interchangeable things I just like to
say for the record in your help Avengers
everyone this is our eighth so we sold
out a movie and we did not run out of
ideas we had one more it was everywhere
and I was back in like the early 2000s
where it's like a beer commercial
discussing I love watching my TV hanging
with my friends and
[Laughter]
manjo era - TV yeah spiked teeth launch
of Spike TV like just when persons were
still fat like girls in bikinis that
they made different versions they made
like a holiday version sama bit and like
every like third line is an twins yes I
should have gotten this show okay as the
lead in yeah the Geico caveman there's
probably a really sad behind the music
for the jingle refuse looked up like
Coors Light and twins you can find every
variation so if you're curious there you
go it's as bad as we say it is yep
keep going Time Bandits yep they are
Avengers suck it avatar and get him
Avengers hey no fair we were ready
do-over
what grown man he's a single small talk
it was a meal is that always take so
tiny
go get chips there to that joke rewind
it has no what appears to be the remains
of a second taco a lot to spare
back rewind a bit more it is hopping
from the top there's too much lettuce in
this talk this is very I'm still here I
thought you meant were the chips shell
remnants that I was like still lettuce
and tomatoes yeah it's a gross taco and
it's not gonna be edgy tyrion scott is
walk still extra in this horrible finger
no now Roxbury chips so there were a
little bit of a supplements now it's so
not still sorry continue
so who plays the dude in the MCU Obadiah
Stane yeah I think that's a very it's a
very very relevant every actor from any
movie that's gonna be in an MCU movie so
I think we did this joke with Captain
America's list in Star Wars yes Windu
yeah there you go
so yeah bring back classics uh Natalie
Portman also Padme Thor's girlfriend
yeah we should talk about the things
that are helpful fans criticized some
mad dr mad doctor says poor rocket
doesn't get mentioned when he goes
through the main surviving characters he
has more screen time than Captain Marvel
- that's a good point we didn't what we
have said if we remembered he's there I
feel like he had a bigger role in
infinity war which is kind of how we
were making these calls like we were
highlighting characters that had more to
do with this musical saying that this
was a conscious decision we forgot we
were going through all the characters we
were gonna write jokes about we
definitely brought up rocket and I made
this exact point and there wasn't really
a joke like Thor this is
I sympathize with with great characters
not being it but this is also not a cram
it right or a review show or review of
the movie a recap of the movie like it's
also like what did we have jokes poor
and respectfully we really did not that
is the one threshold week sometimes
barely mentioned spider-man if at all
right all right uh someone asks in my my
my first ever honest trailer I've
ignored it and heard about it and I
realize I've been missing out it's
fabulous time to bend Raj everything we
got one it's Ryan from picking that one
out nice okay so one more thing we need
to discuss because we've been talking
long enough and there are a lot of
questions or observations about it is
there was a raptor yes didn't notice you
know yeah your eagle eyes did not fail
you a raptor walked out of one of the
portals and said Alan for those of you
who are maybe just joining us yes
what is that Dan and why why did that
happen
that is the Alan Raptor yes last year
shortly before the events of an infinity
war Amish trailer we featured Jurassic
Park three the yacht's trailer and
there's a raptor in that film that says
the word Alan that it's our favorite and
syndrome sequence it's a dream sequence
but still very funny and subsequent
trailers we would hide an Alan Raptor
somewhere in the trailer well tragically
in the events of the infinity war honest
trailer Alan the Alan Raptor was dusted
along with so many of our beloved heroes
and he has now along been snapped back
into existence and so you may once again
perhaps see whole pockets and everything
yeah
it was carrying on him everything all of
his claws scales feathers we're
committing to the return of well our
editor who has to actually do it is
committing to hiding another Ellen in
every on in Turner and you can go back
for everyone between Jurassic Park 3 and
infinity war there's a hidden Allen
Allen Raptors back unfortunately he
didn't aged in the whole time good man
well he's several million years old
right sir a few more weeks guys that's
all the time we have today I want to
leave you with a tease for next week's
Australia which is a movie I think we
really are only going up from here as
far as notoriety and discussion you know
the fact that like people are talking
about this one so much yeah really on
the pulse of the SEO yeah it's gonna be
a real view getter yeah gonna be
gangbusters but it does sort of feature
time travel not time travel so much is
different portable portals yeah a portal
from our world to others in between
dimensions of time and space doable
villain and a notable very notable doing
so those are your clues then Danielle
flan Joe thank you so much for joining
me and thank you for joining us we hope
to come back next week for another
episode of honest trailer commentaries
bye
[Music]
you